[Music]
on this Sunday night backing Ukraine G7
Nations pledge new Aid in the war are
you satisfied with the support that
Canada's been given to Ukraine as Russia
claims victory in the battle for a buck
moot but Ukraine says not so fast
the fight to protect Fox Creek Alberta
plus the anxiety among homesick evacuees
Canada's daycare deserts it really is a
horror story for for families which
provinces have it the worst and the
possible solutions and praise from
Princess Anne what the Royal had to say
to a Canadian regiment
global national we Ed with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us a G7 Summit unlike any other has
wrapped up in Japan and while the to-do
list of pressing World issues was long
Ukraine's defense against Russia's
invasion was at the top of the agenda
especially with President Vladimir
zielinski's surprise appearance leaders
of the world's most powerful democracies
are largely United on helping Ukraine
but there was disagreement about another
unrelated issue Mackenzie gray explains
in our top story tonight
a hug and a handshake for the world's
most sought after man it's so nice to be
able to see you in person and it's happy
to see you thank you very much thank you
your government of course Canadian
people for supporting us
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
barnstorming his way through the G7
getting new weapon and aid from allies
including a 375 million dollar bundle
from Joe Biden package that includes
more ammunition artillery armored
vehicles to bolster Ukraine's
Battlefield abilities that's in contrast
with Canada who only announced new
sanctions and an openness to train
Ukrainian Pilots when asked by global
news about a lack of new Canadian Aid
zielinski hinted a new deal was coming
soon are you satisfied with the support
that Canada has been giving to Ukraine
in the last number of months
I would like you to understand
we have powerful relations with Canada
there are some of the poems which may be
publicly cannot be commented so far we
don't have anything to make public we
are working on something but Canada is
supporting us the immediate Ukrainian
ask of Canada real pleasure to be with
you today to win over Brazil president
Lula de Silva has previously said
Ukraine should give up Crimea and that
both Kiev and Moscow were equally
responsible for the war
Justin Trudeau wouldn't say if Lula
budged instead reaffirming Canada would
support kiev for the Long Haul
had we not been there with significant
Military Support
Ukraine would not be standing today and
while there's Unity on the war
Justin Trudeau found himself in a rare
fight with a G7 member Canada is
concerned about some of the some of the
positionings that Italy is taking in
terms of LGBT rights that comment from
Trudeau referencing a directive by the
Italian government to limit parental
recognition of lgbtq couples
leading the Italian Prime Minister to
say Trudeau was a victim of fake news
and propaganda it's an issue that
matters deeply to me into Canadians and
I said what was necessary to be said the
Summit is now wrapped but the Prime
Minister believes the choice of
Hiroshima to host the G7 will continue
to serve as an important reminder to the
leaders of the horrors of nuclear war as
the Specter of a Russian nuclear attack
hangs over the conflict in Ukraine Farah
Mackenzie gray and Hiroshima Japan thank
you for that Mackenzie and during
President zielinski's visit in Japan
Russia came out claiming the longest
Battle of the war was over after months
of fierce fighting the Kremlin says a
russian-backed forces have taken control
of the Eastern Ukrainian city of bakmut
as Redmond Shannon explains zielinski
appeared to confirm that Victory only to
roll it back later on
a wartime leader acknowledging and
reflecting on the most horrific end to a
war ever known Vladimir zielinski
alongside Japanese prime minister fumio
kishida at the Hiroshima Peace Memorial
a reminder of how two U.S atomic bombs
killed at least 100
000 people in Hiroshima and Nagasaki 78
years ago zielinski said the old images
of destroyed Hiroshima reminded him of
the city of bakmut Ukraine as it looks
today on Sunday Russian TV showed the
gutted remains of bakmut along with a
statement of congratulations from
Vladimir Putin the Kremlin now says back
moot has been fully captured from
Ukraine after a nine-month battle led by
the Russian mercenary Wagner group
in a second such message of the weekend
the head of Wagner yevgeni pragosian
said there are no Ukrainian so soldiers
in bakmut because we have stopped taking
prisoners it has been captured down to
the last centimeter back in Hiroshima
zielinski initially appeared to confirm
the news
in Ukraine's hands
the Russians say they've taken upward I
think no
but you have to to understand that there
is nothing they destroyed everything but
with Ukrainian forces claiming they
still had a foothold zelenski later
clarified saying the battle is not over
they are in Baku today where exactly I'm
not going to tell you but this means
that bakmut has not been conquered by
Russia at this point it may be semantics
or just a matter of time before Russia
holds 100 control of bakmut zelenski
said that his soldiers who remain are
fulfilling an important task likely
referring to their continuation of a
long battle that has drained Russian
resources
that ahead of the anticipated Ukrainian
counter-offensive something zelenski
says Russia will feel when it happens
much of the land Ukraine aims to retake
is now little more than just that land
Redmond Shannon Global News London
there's relief in the forecast for
hundreds of firefighters battling
wildfires in Northern Alberta rain and
cooler temperatures are expected in the
days to come after a tense few days in
Fox Creek Northwest of Edmonton as Blake
law explains the fire threatening the
town has finally reached its defenses
buzzing overhead a parade of helicopters
dropped bucket after bucket of water on
smoldering hot spots
a flurry of activity along Highway 43
just north of Fox Creek layer after
layer of Fire Guard dug up around the
community has succeeded in keeping the
Flames out to my understanding the fire
has not moved to closer to the
communities and we are continuing to
work hard to hold it the highway that
had been closed since Friday now finally
reopened but police warned the threat is
still very real and are cautioning those
who can finally get through to go slow
there are active fire operations going
on to suppress slow down deplete the
fire of its fuel resources right and
that's not just on the ground but we
also do have air support that is up
there still early in the season
wildfires in Alberta have scorched
nearly 1 million hectares of land well
we're optimistic that the forecast rain
will be enough to make a difference to
some wildfires in the province we are
not out of the woods yet very anxious to
get home and that has happened right
since the beginning Fox Creek mayor
Sheila Gilmore says she's seen her
community go through a range of emotions
from fear and frustration to a feeling
of defeat but the most recent reports
are positive there's some optimism there
for sure but we just need to see the
rain start and then I think things will
feel a lot better Fox Creek after so
many days of scorching dry heat is now
under a rainfall warning 50 to 75
millimeters is expected by Wednesday
it's rainfall that for many albertans
can't come soon enough
Blake law Global News Fox Creek Alberta
and on that note the change in weather
could help Alberta's air quality which
is now among the worst in the world
take a look at this air quality map from
IQ air and you can see Alberta is
highlighted in red signifying the
severely unhealthy conditions right now
the purple spots even worse and this is
what Edmonton looked like today with
smoke smothering the whole city the air
quality Health index is a 10 plus which
is very high risk the conditions have
led to several long weekend activities
being canceled now Calgary is Smoky too
but it's not as bad the air quality
Health index there is a lot lower at
three
from raging wildfires here in Canada to
catastrophic flooding overseas there's a
new look tonight at the devastation
Rising Waters have caused in Northern
Italy
36 000 people have been forced from
their homes many stranded residents
don't have electricity last week some
areas were inundated with six months
worth of rain in just 36 hours the death
toll remains unchanged at 14. the
Italian government will meet on Tuesday
to decide on Emergency Response measures
a stampede at a soccer stadium in El
Salvador's Capital has killed at least
12 people and injured dozens of others
video posted to social media shows the
aftermath with emergency crews treating
people on the field before taking them
to hospital the Stampede erupted during
a playoff soccer game police and
Witnesses say angry ticket holders were
locked out before the game prompting
them to storm the stadium investigators
believe too many tickets both real and
fake were sold El Salvador's government
is promising a thorough investigation
allegations of Chinese interference in
Canadian democracy have dugged the Prime
Minister for months Justin Trudeau has
been resisting calls for a public
inquiry into the matter instead he's
appointed former Governor General David
Johnston to decide whether an inquiry is
necessary as our chief political
correspondent David Aiken explains
Johnston will make his recommendation
public on Tuesday
conservatives think David Johnston needs
to make just one recommendation we want
to see him call for a full public
independent inquiry I think that's what
Canadians want I think that's what we
need to have to get the answers the
block quebecois wants the same thing and
so too do the new Democrats we're
looking for a public inquiry I mean the
leader has been very clear and as the
first person to ask for it people across
this country need to know that our
electoral system is working we want to
make sure that foreign interference is
being dealt with in a meaningful way
liberals on the other hand have been
more ambivalent about the need for a
public inquiry I am looking for him to
lay out a whole process as to how to
deal with this in a way that can clarify
the situation respect National Security
concerns and and you know all the
obligations that we have to the people
who are collecting this information for
our different agencies as well as for
all our allies David Johnston was
appointed governor general under Stephen
Harper's conservative government even
with that and with Johnston's back
background is a constitutional law
expert the conservatives believe
Johnston is in a hopelessly compromised
position he is Justin Trudeau's ski
buddy his Cottage neighbor his family
friend and a member of the Trudeau
Foundation which got 140
000 dollars from Beijing
he has a fake job and he's unable to do
it impartially but whatever Johnston
recommends in Tuesday's report Trudeau
is already on the record saying he will
follow those recommendations so if
Johnson does recommend a public inquiry
Trudeau is going to make it happen
pharah
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you for that
David it's becoming more affordable but
there's still no guarantee parents can
find child care in the first place
coming up how common daycare deserts
have become
protesters in France aren't giving up
fighting those widely unpopular pension
reforms demonstrators today March near
the prestigious Cannes Film Festival
angry president Emmanuel McCall passed a
law last month raising the retirement
age from 62 to 64. authorities have
largely stopped the protests from
disrupting the star-studded event
Banning rallies throughout much of the
city
well child care is an elusive dream for
many Canadian parents the federal
government has promised to make it
cheaper with a 10 a day program but
there's another major hurdle having
enough facilities to meet the demand as
Brittany Rosen explains some parts of
Canada are experiencing daycare deserts
putting your child in daycare has become
much more affordable thanks to each
provinces deal with Ottawa to slash the
price to ten dollars a day over the next
five years but now that the price
barriers have been broken demand for
child care has skyrocketed creating yet
another hurdle for parents finding a
spot it really is a horror story for for
families often people will try and put
themselves on waiting lists when they
discover that they're pregnant
and still they won't get a child care
space a new report from the Canadian
Center of policy Alternatives is
highlighting just how dire the situation
is in Canada it says out of nearly 2
million children below the age of
Eligibility to enter kindergarten 946
000 are living in daycare deserts
meaning at least three children per
postal code are competing for a single
spot it's really awful for families a
huge stressor and really impacts the
ability of one parent typically the
mother to participate in the workforce
among the provinces with the highest
proportion of younger children living in
child care deserts Saskatchewan which
saw 92 percent Newfoundland and Labrador
at 79 percent and Manitoba with 76
percent a critical part of the problem
according to experts is assured of Early
Childhood Educators Child Care trained
staff with a couple of years of college
education are paid as if they only had a
high school education according to the
report Pei in Quebec had the lowest
rates of child care deserts they did
their major reforms on affordability
back in the late 1990s and the turn of
the century the early 2000s and so
they've been working on the problem for
25 years to expand access to child care
experts say raising staff wages
investing in non-profits and expanding
before and after school programs will
ease the burden on Early Childhood
Educators Brittany Rosen Global News
Toronto
[__]
lies in deceit ahead how scammers are
swindling unsuspecting victims with
increasingly creative cons
[Music]
are always trying to find fresh clever
ways to get your cash no matter the
method they know they can succeed if
they scare you one Calgary woman
recently got duped after she'd been told
she was hacked and is tamasia Da Silva
explains it shows just how tech savvy
fraudsters have become
oh they are smooth they are smooth
talkers
very convincing so convincing that with
just one phone call they conned Jennifer
Agnew out of 2500 bucks
I should have seen the red flags that
phone call supposedly from a fraud
investigator with Amazon she was told
her account had been hacked a package
was on the way to someone else and she
would have to pay a cool Grant unless
she acted now I put in the app he asked
me to that app any desk the remote
software application was supposed to get
her access to Amazon's secure site
instead it gave the scammer access to
everything on her phone he was literally
right in my phone
yep
including text conversations she was
having at that very moment at the time
my boyfriend was texting me and the guy
on the other end was like why are you
getting text messages
why is your boyfriend telling you this
is a scam she realized it was but it was
too late she had opened another app one
for a digital wallet sending the scammer
the money I didn't want to lose my money
well I lost it anyway because it was a
total
scam those apps have a lot of power and
your security expert Amanda Swain says
anytime you install new software
especially if someone asks you to you
need to consider the dangers a lot of
these tools have dual purposes as I may
install it or get you like get my mom to
install it so I can help her
troubleshoot some of her phone issues
but a scammer can use it for the same
methods to try and extract information
from you abstract payment from you
exactly what these smooth criminals did
to mausi to Silva Global News
Royal respect next Princess Anne Praises
Canada's oldest regiment as it marks a
military milestone
[Music]
people in New Brunswick got a rare
opportunity to catch a glimpse of
royalty this May long weekend the sister
of King Charles Princess Anne was in The
Province for a three-day tour and as
Megan King explains the Royal also
visited Canada's oldest military
regiment
the third and final day of Princess
Anne's visit to New Brunswick marked the
175th anniversary of the 8th Canadian
husar's Regiment of which she's colonel
in Chief
the Princess Royal first arrived in
downtown Moncton Friday morning via
helicopter laying a wreath at the
memorial honoring the three RCMP members
killed in the 2014 shooting and speaking
with the families of the slain officers
Saturday she donned the hussar's red and
blue colors the latest of several visits
since being appointed to her role with
the regiment in June 1972 when she was
just 21. there's a very deliberate
process of what we wanted to display how
we wanted to emphasize our members their
families her emphasis has been and I
think it always has has been and always
will be an interest in in the soldiers
how the soldiers are feeling how they're
trained what their morale is like what
their experiences are like so on the
parade you've seen it she stops and
speaks to soldiers individually and I
can attest to the fact that she is
keenly interested it's very engaging the
eighth Canadian husar's Commanding
Officer says the Princess Royal voiced
her pleasure with how the regiment is
operating very intelligent questions
yearly the regiment would be sending her
Royal Highness a situation report via
VTC or on the telephone it just so
happens that this year we were able to
do it face to face which is basically
the gold standard
a Rainier Day on Sunday Princess Anne
left Moncton for Sussex New Brunswick
unveiling a plaque at Museum Square to
celebrate the anniversary we had to come
because Anne is the only daughter and
she is represents I think the monarchy
and she the duty and the service
amassing crowds of hundreds of people
over the course of the trip Princess
Anne ended her New Brunswick visit back
at the greater Moncton Romeo LeBlanc
International Airport boarding a plane
for Montreal making King Global News
Halifax
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew here I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
long weekend with us tonight's here
Canada is Edmonton's annual vasaki nagar
kirtan parade
[Applause]
Community is celebrating its culture
this May long weekend the parade marks
the creation of the collective faith of
Sikhism and is the beginning of the
harvest season Sophie Louie will be at
the anchor desk tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign